Sorry. Excuse me.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, everyone.
(INDISTINCT CHATTER CONTINUES)
Listen up!
First, I wanna thank you all
for coming here today
to honor my dear Betty.
(SIGHS) But there's
something else I'd like to say,
and I gotta get it off my chest.
I was gonna tell Betty,
but now it looks like
that isn't gonna happen.
And I can't live with
this anymore.
I can't live with the guilt.
I had an affair...
with Helen Fahey.
(SNORTS)
(COUGHING)
(LAUGHS)
Listen-- Listen to me.
Affair's a strong word,
very strong.
It happened twice.
(CACKLING)
Okay, three times, tops.
But, you know, the fact
that I can't even remember
how many should tell you
all you need to know
about what it meant to me.
(CONTINUES LAUGHING)
I mean, what kind of
smack-the-ass makes
an announcement like that
at his wife's funeral reception
anyway?
(LAUGHING CONTINUES)
Oh.
♪ (WHIMSICAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
(DOORBELL RINGS)
Ma, what do you think?
I thought you were wearing
the red dress with the thing?
I tried, didn't work.
No, no, no. Go back
and try the red dress again.
(KNOCK ON DOOR)
He's at the door. Mom?
Oh, well, in that case,
you look great.
(SIGHS) Home wrecker.
Holy shit.
-Let's go.
Bye!